we've all heard the news
Zayn has left one direction and we're
all day we're all dead we're all so
devastated by this fact but let's not be
in pain because of same rhyme intended
sane wouldn't want it that way would he
it's time to move on
One Direction deserves a new member
who's as strong as beautiful as great of
a singer or even better in all these
three so I would like to nominate myself
now I know what you're thinking and he's
just making a joke here is that serious
I'm 100 100 percent serious
so I listed five things that I think
would make me a great band member number
one I already know all the lyrics to
every single song baby you light up my
world like nobody else the way that you
flip your ear gets me over number two I
can hit all the high notes flawlessly
number three just like Zane I'm
beautiful number four I look great in a
bikini is that sadness
and number five and finally I've been
dedicated to the One Direction fan base
or Gears damn it this should be an
attractive baby Oh God fantastic this is
my chance this is my moment I've waited
for this and I just started damn it yeah
sorry
sorry I'm still sad over say me I know
it would be a very drastic change so to
ease you into the idea of me being part
of one direction I have some pictures
that one might convince you see doesn't
it just feel natural doesn't it just
feel right doesn't it just feel like
there's this empty void that has finally
been filled now I don't like this but I
promise Edgar then I'd show what it
looks like if he's part of one direction
too so if you want to kick out Louis
while you're at it I mean let's be
honest I'm really doing any job 30pi
Zayn you promised you wouldn't steal my
spot man Zayn I never promised that you
know how much this means to me
I thought we were friends you
manipulated me come calm the [ __ ] down
Zayn but alright calm down
that's it I'm leaving alright well
that'll be the second time for one day
what - Zayn now that Zane's gone
consider me because I worked hard for
this dammit and I deserve it let me know
if you agree and I'll see you bros in
one direction stay awesome Directioners
gross
Wow